okay so I'll just start hell everyone
thanks for coming I'm Sean and today
I'll be talking about theoretical and
practical insights from linear
Transformers
so as we know uh large language models
work surprisingly well in practice and
the basis of large language models is
the Transformer neuron Network so
important question is why do
Transformers work and how can we train
them effectively but um directly this
question is uh difficult to answer
because large language models have
billions maybe even trillions of
parameters um they have a lot of moving
Parts different choices of normalization
of embedding and they contain many
different kinds of modules so it is
important uh to to have a mathematical
struction that captures the essence of
Transformer learning and optimization in
order to better understand
Transformers
and today we are going to look at how
the simple linear Transformer Can Shed
light on two important questions one is
the mechanism behind a phenomenal known
as in context learning and two um I'll
tell you about how linear Transformer
optimization shares many of the
unconventional features of real
transformer optimization and these uh
two points are based on two papers which
are in join work with quanum had and Ali
from MIT as well as mhak charie from
chist okay so part one will be
understanding in context
learning so what is in context learning
a very standard task of large language
models is that of next word prediction
for example uh you can give GPT a prompt
Mary has a little blank and it tells you
you know Mary has a little lamp but
that's not so surprising because you
know somewhere in this training data it
probably saw this exact sentence maybe
thousands of
times uh so then in context learning
refers to the following kind of
prompting so I'll provide GPT with a few
demonstrations right I'll say apple is
red banana is yellow uh then what is a
grape and then so apple red and banana
yellow serve as contextual
examples and based off of these
contextual examples gbt in first that
I'm looking for the color of the fruit
so it feels in
purple and this phenomenon even works
for uh arbitrary made up rules right so
like this is a bunch of gibberish but uh
the at symbol denotes concatenation and
it correctly infers that at denotes
concatenation so it probably didn't
hasn't seen this exact example any where
train is that but you know it still does
the right thing um I would say that uh I
tried some very complicated uh you know
gibberish and it doesn't work there so
um that's a good thing I guess because
otherwise we are all out of jobs
soon
um
and so uh to the best of my knowledge
this Inc context learning phenomenon was
first reported in a seminal paper by
brown man Rider subia and collaborators
and this paper is
because they the you know e um and uh so
this paper was also the one that coin
the phrase uh in context learning I
think um I would also say that you you
know from a machine learning point of
view if you give your model a few
demonstrations and then it does well on
those demonstrations it's not terribly
surprising right because but but the
thing is here in context Learning Works
without any updates to the model
parameters right so you know I'm not
doing any fine-tuning I'm just using the
same Transformer and then it does the
right thing so that that's I guess the
surprising thing some people even go as
far as claim that it's one of the main
reasons for why large language models
work so well in practice but uh
regardless understanding why how large
models do in context learning is a very
important question uh to us
understanding large models so
um and in recent years there's uh a few
very uh important papers that that try
to shed light on this phenomenon uh aork
is based on a few of these papers so
I'll do a quick review of the relevant
literature uh the first such paper is
the one by gar cus leang vant
2022 and uh the title is what can
Transformers luring context a case study
of simple function classes so recall the
example about fruits and colors and the
hidden rule is that you know Y is a
color of X where X is some fruit and Y
is some color but it's very hard to
reason about uh you know what does it
mean what kind of function is
represented by you know the question
about color in say the embedding space
of words so what they propos to do is
consider a simp simplified setup where
your X are ukan vectors and the Y's are
linearly related to X by some unobserved
data so it's a linear regression problem
pictorially you know you're given a
bunch of
demonstrations uh the black dot XY Pairs
and then uh the question is in the form
of the Red Dot XM plus one and uh you're
trying to figure out what the label Y is
the resolution is a bit low
but kind of make this
okay
so uh a followup paper by aak Sherman's
Andreas Ma and zo in
2023 um they further try to characterize
what kind of
uh uh or they try to characterize how
Transformers are able to learn these
functions such as linear function and
um that the the main tap way here is
that Transformer can the learning
contexts because they are able to
implement various learning gorithms for
example this plot here shows that
experimentally Transformers appear to
implement the ordinary least squares um
algorithm on noisess data so um the
green line is like zero throughout and
so it has a very so so the Transformer
prediction has a very good agreement
with ordinary
Leist and the way they show that
Transformers are able to implement um
this learning algorithm is approved by
Construction so they have this very
clever construction where they Define a
few you know algorithmic primitive like
multiplication division uh fine
transformation and they show that
attention the attention unit can
implement this Primitives so by you know
hooking together various attention units
you're able to implement algorithms such
as vs and I'll mention here that further
along this direction there are also more
extreme examples where people show that
you know the tension architecture can
Implement like uh I know some kind of
register system or something so you can
Implement arbitrary algorithms and you
know Transformers can be thought of as
programmable
computers um the catch is that you know
all these constructions are very clever
but the downside is that also means
they're very fragile and it's uh unclear
whether these very clever constructions
are actually recovered when you say
train your Transformer with adom
algorithm so next in line are two papers
linear Transformers are secretly fast
programs by SCH Irish mid Hoover in 2021
and a closely related paper
by in
CL sacremental
more more and blood mirov in so um I'll
mainly focus on the second paper um
Transformers learning contacts by gring
descent and so here as well they do
approv by construction but there is a
very important difference from previous
papers which is they consider the linear
Transformer which is so all previous um
papers they consider they may consider a
simplified setting where the problem is
linear regression but the architecture
was always full Transformers but here um
it's the first time people look at
linear Transformers which I'll Define a
bit but it's a simpler it's simpler than
uh for Transformers and because they
look at linear Transformers they're able
to provide a very simple
construction where under under which
linear Transformers are able to
implement rating descent uh and which in
turn allows them to learn linear
functions in context and remarkably they
have some you know pretty convincing
experiments uh which agree with their
construction okay so that's for prior
work and now I come to our paper where
we try to uh answer the question the
following question so TR we saw that
Transformers are expressive enough to
implement a whole bunch of algorithms
but can we show the Transformers
actually learn to implement any of these
algorithms during
training so let let me set up the
problem uh when you have a Transformer
the input is uh of the form of a matrix
uh D byn where you can think of it as a
horizontally stacked bunch of tokens
each token is kind of like a word in a
sentence so your sentence will get you
know eded in Cent space and turn into a
bunch of factors and so if you want to
yeah um the standard self attention uh
module is the following function
essentially so you have your key value
query Matrix um you have a mask which
for this cality and then uh you put a
soft Max on
the on this
okay and linear self attention is
basically the same thing except we take
a the sof Max so there's no softmax and
that's why it's called linear because we
took out the
nonlinearity and by the same time I
would say that um the word the phrase
linear attention is maybe a bit of a
misnomer because the linear attention
module is not linear in either the
parameters pqk or in its input Z in fact
it's a third order polinomial of c and
because of this the repres uh the
representation power when you stack a
bunch of these linear attention modules
on top of each other it increases so
this is in contrast to something like a
say linear fully connect in your network
so no matter how many of this you stack
you always are a linear function of a
input but you can actually represent
increasingly High degree polinomial by
stacking linear attenion
units and uh the linear Transformer
which we'll look at is basically you
know stacking these attention units by a
residual connection um and to be precise
you know this is a single-headed uh
single-headed uh
Transformer okay so that's uh defining
the linear Transformer architecture and
now let me uh properly set up the
learning objective so as mentioned
earlier the input to a Transformer is a
sequence of tokens and in the linear
regression setting each token Z is
consist consists of XY pair where X is a
d dimensional ukian Vector Y is a scalar
and XY are related by this lar
relationship and Theta store is
unobserved and on top of that each
prompt has a different data store the
goal uh you also given a uh XM plus one
but without the label ym plus one and
the goal is to uh train the Transformer
to predict the hidden label given the
demonstrations as well as XM plus
one oh I will stress that this problem
is uh much harder than
simply uh learning a single Theta star
because Theta star changes from prompt
to prompt so you need to learn an
algorithm that you know given a few
demonstrations in first the right T
store regardless of what the T store
is and at this point I would also
mention that one of the reasons for uh
choosing to focus on linear attention as
opposed to softmax attention besides the
fact that linear tension is simpler and
easier to understand is that for this
problem of you know learning a linear
function linear Transformers perform
much better than soft Max uh
Transformers um and and I guess we'll
see uh concretely why that is in a bit
but even now just intuitively right
right if your data are linearly related
then it makes sense that
softmax um doesn't really help you all
that
much so okay so here's the first result
I'll talk about we study one layer
linear Transformer and we claim that it
implements one step of gradient descent
at Global minimum so what does it mean
for a Transformer to implement one step
of gradient descent
on the left here in this box I show the
architecture of a one layer linear
Transformer is very simple you have a z
it passes through an uh a single
attention layer and then you know we get
some output TF Z comma W where t f
subscript l z comma W denotes the
Transformers prediction at layer l given
input Z and parameters W so parameters W
is like the Cur key value
matrices and uh we try to minimize the
Inc T loss which is the expected
difference between the prediction and
the true label and the expectation is
taken over both uh Z which is the input
as well as Theta star which is the you
know unobserved linear
relationship and uh if you forget about
Transformers for a bit a very reasonable
thing to try to do when given a bunch of
demonstrations and you need to infert
the correct label is to maintain a data
and then run GD and descent on it right
with respect to the uh empirical Lisk
grass floss which iight
in and uh so here
I I just play One Step a single step of
grading descent on the in dispersal and
if n is sufficiently large you know
you'll probably do
decently so theorem one of our paper
says the following if you assume that
the coat are sample from the standard
noral distribution and Theta St is also
simple from the standard normal
distribution then the linear Transformer
that minimizes the in context loss FW
which is in red gives the same
prediction as the onestep gradient
descent on R Theta which I highlight in
purple so in other words the output
tf1 uh of Z comma
W is the same as if you ran one step of
gradient descent on Theta and use that
to predict the label
and uh in fact you can consider a more
general setting when your coat are
sampled from some uh distribution with a
non-identity cence so when your cence is
Sigma here the linear Transformer that
globally minimizes the loss now corres
coincides with one running one step of
preconditioned grent descent where the
prec conditioner
a is given by the
following um for when n is very large
which is when you're you're given a ton
of
demonstrations of uh you know XY
pairs a uh in the limit is just inverse
of your um cence Matrix uh Co The cence
Matrix of your
cence um but when n is small or there's
this regular additional
regularization is it obvious that the
global minimum is is it obvious that the
global minimum is unique and if not is
this a statement about any Global
minimum yeah so this is a statement
about any Global minimum in fact um
there there is some obvious
uh you know um no spaces in the laws I
guess because one example is uh the
query times key Matrix you can scale
them arbitrarily if their product is the
same then does the same um another
example is you know since this is a
linear Transformer scaling the value Key
current matri arbitr as long as they
multiply to the same thing also gives
the exact same
predictor um but then you one might
wonder you know ignoring these
invariances is that unique I'm not sure
I'm not sure empirically it all in all
our experiments this is always recovered
so um that's a good sign and also I'm as
I'm just about to mention um there are
two concurrent Works which appear
shortly after we publish the initial
draft one of them characterizes Global
optimality for one layer linear
Transformer on the similar setting so
similar result as ours and the second
paper by zre and baret in 2023 on top of
characterizing global optimality they
show that if you run grent descend on
the uh linear Transformer with some
specific initialization or some specific
conditions on initialization you always
converge to uh the
this so um at least you know it's a good
region of Attraction based off of this
results uh uh but I'm not sure if it's
Unique thank
you okay so that's for one layer leading
Transformer implementing One S of gr but
in practice you know uh Transformers are
work better when there's lots of layers
and gring descent works better when
there's lots of steps so then natural
question is can extend a similar result
to a l layer linear transformer for some
arbitrary integer l so on the left again
I show um a l layer linear Transformer
same in context leing loss but this time
the the is after
lers and in the middle I show L steps of
grent descent again with respect to the
same iner this
SC and uh here the establish a weaker
guarantee so instead of saying that grad
descent is a global Optimum we only show
that there exist Transformers which are
stationary points of the Inc contact
loss um such that at every layer the
Transformer give the same prediction as
L steps of gradient descent on our so in
other words TF2 would correspond to the
prediction using 2 tf1 corresponds to
the
prediction one and so on for each L uh
and that's kind of interesting because
um really the the only thing you're
training on is uh have capital L right
and so it's interesting that all these
intermediate outputs have a
interpretable connection to
gradient
question
this there exist
Transformers uh I'm trying to figure out
the quantification uh there exist
Transformers that for a random choice of
these of these
parameters uh what parameters what's the
quantification on the on the uh the X
and the
Theta X and are you saying at the very
beginning of the theorem very beginning
of theorem three yes X and Thea are here
expectation so I Define a loss on
Transformer key value M query matrices
which is only a function of w that is
expectation over uh Z which is I guess
XY and Theta of the prediction minus the
true label and there are stationary
points of this loss F of w such that um
you know the stationary point is some
specific choice of key value current
matrices so if you non identity but
Sigma and here U we assume Theta star is
from Sigma inverse and you know the
there stationary points which coincide
with uh
preconditioned where the preconditioner
is
s are these local Minima can like sorry
can you construct one which is also a
local minimum I'm not sure we tried uh
but but we couldn't show it but uh so so
which is why we only show stationary
Point um okay let let me show you one
more slide so
experimentally um
so so we only show that there exist
stationary points right but
experimentally surprisingly we always
recover the same key value matrices so
specifically Transformer implements
precondition gradient descent by Sigma
inverse If the product of Key C matrices
is uh Sigma inverse and so here I I
train a three layer Transformer and I
display Sigma
half key Sig and we see that each of
these cases is identity pretty much so
in other words it's always learning to
implementation so I think that we don't
have a theory for it but I think there's
um you know we conjecture that maybe
these um are in fact locally or even
globally op but um yeah so so it's
something worth thinking
about uh before I end I will also
mention that um I skimmed a bit of
detail on characterizing this term we
actually need to assume certain
sparsities specific the last row and
column of the keyur matrices are zero
and there are actually two variants of
this theorem um depending on what kind
of constraints we impose on the value
Matrix uh you could Implement
precondition gradient descent or
something more clever than precondition
gradient descent which inter leaps
gradient steps with uh rotation of the
gra Matrix to make things better
condition you can see the details of all
this in
our okay so that's all for the first
part of the talk and I'm almost out of
time but maybe I'll quickly talk about
the second part which is how linear
Transformer lost landscape vers a number
of remarkable similarities to the Lo
landscape of full Transformer
optimization so again Transformers are
large and complicated and it's difficult
to pinpoint why algorithm works or it
doesn't work and it's difficult to
theoretically analyze the behavior of
optimization algorithms also it's very
expensive to experiment on food
Transformers on the other hand linear
Transformers may be a useful model to
understand Transformer optimization so
we surveyed a number of of recent papers
which look at the Transformer the
optimization landscape of food
Transformers we observe uh and we
identify sever remarkable features which
are kind of unique to Transformer
optimization and we observe that shallow
linear Transformers on linear on the
linear regression problem has uh similar
optimization features so one example is
that adom is significantly faster than
stochastic grad in descent for uh
Transformer training um on the left and
this is a phenomenon that's kind of
unique to large language models and
Transformers so on the left uh this plot
is taken from
construction3 on the left uh the two
plots we show training a CNN on amist
and C so is a image test and there's no
obvious gap between SGD and AD but on
the right they show three Transformers
on different dat set and there's a clear
gap between Adam and similar
observations were also made in a number
of other recent papers and we show here
on the left it's uh you know the same PL
just from the prev slide for the three
kinds of language test and here on the
right I show a three layer linear
Transformer train on linear regression
and we see that similarly there is a
significant gap between and and the
coincide with slightly different
settings of the kind
of and I'm already over time so maybe
I'll skip over the rest of the features
but uh know long story short that
there's a number of features which are
kind of unique to transform optimization
and people conjecture that's maybe why
adaptive algorithms are so important
when training large language models and
so we went through each of them and we
uh checked if you get the same kind of
plots or or data that you get from
training a simple linear Transformer and
in each of this case that there's a
surprising agreement with what people
observe for full Transformers what
people observe for uh you know Shadow
trans so um with that I will end the
talk and any
[Applause]
questions any more questions for
[Music]
Chan so I I've heard that uh actual
large language model training is like
unstable and you you look at the
training PL there places where you get
like these spikes um are are those
instabilities also replicated in the
smaller Transformers that you consider
yeah um they are uh in fact uh we we
have a guess for why some of the
instability is happening and it goes
back to the fact that you know
Transformer appears to be learning to
implement this gradient descent
algorithms and the thing with gradient
descent is that um the closer your the
larger your step size is the better you
do until the point where you exceed the
lip shift constant that things flow very
quickly so we also observe that you know
as your loss gets lower and lower and
your learning rate per layer I guess is
getting close to the boundary Things
become more unstable because if you just
exceed that by a little bit um your
transform the kind of optimization
algorithm that's Implement a bi
transform diverg so that's one example
but yeah we do observe
similar
so so you showed the linear transform of
one layer is equivalent to
gradient empirical squares yes one step
of gradient uh for L lays they actually
implement the preconditioned
gradient yeah so for both um for both uh
let let me go
back
so for
linear uh for for one layer we we show
we show that you know if the the cence
is Sigma it also implements one step of
precondition yeah and then for L layer
um if data Coan is identity okay it just
does l steps of uh standard gradient
descent but again if uh if the coant is
Sigma then it does l steps of
precondition so it's kind of like two
orthogonal so the linear Transformer
actually is nonlinear in Z right yeah so
that means this non lineal minimization
actually
automatically Implement precondition yes
yes that is corre okay so that's
different way to think about these algs
and they adaptively automatically choose
what precondition it is yes exactly
that's a very good point
interes
um just one question you mentioned if
you add soft Max um in this linear
regression task is actually gonna uh
underperform compared to the linear
model right uh I didn't understand what
was the reason this is kind of so if did
you try like chat gpt2 model or no we
code up a soft Max with the same number
of parameter so so we coulded up some
linear Transformer and take a soft Max
to the place where which is Stick it to
make a soft Max
so it's not like a giant model I see so
there is without any residual
connections right oh with residual so
it's the basically these two are exact
almost exactly the same except you know
we have a soft Max here and we don't so
um maybe let me show you so so both are
look like
this um except different slight
difference in how ATN is defined one
thisof what was the intuition that why
makes her yeah that's a very good
question so um here's an example right
you know if I'm trying to predict Y and
I have some X and in my demonstrations I
had minus
X right um then that should be very
informative to predicting X if you know
it's linear but soft Max would uh
compute the you know product which is a
netive number and that becomes um uh
that then you you put very little weight
on that sample and so that sample became
useless for prediction and that's just
one example I guess overall it's just
that
uh you know B based on the construction
which I didn't show the linear
Transformer very easily implements a
gradient design step softmax Transformer
not so much because softmax sticks out
it does this weird weighing of your
demonstration samples which doesn't
really help in the linear regression
setting so um but probably softmax
Transformer Works more generally you
know um if it's not but this very like
the optimal algorithm for this problem
uh that that's a good question um I
don't know um but I guess you know
whatever algorithm that's of Max is
just thank
you thank you um I had a clarification
question so you mentioned that uh
there's a different theeta star for each
input prompt does do your results also
depend on how many prompts or
demonstrations are provided as part of
in context
learning
uh good question
um yes because so here n is the length
of the prompt okay and um how much
regularization you put
here um depends on n and I guess what
this effect
is uh how I guess what preconditioner
you use exactly so this is for the
nonidentity cence case and even for the
identity cence case the exact step size
I think would be affected depending on
so so you know this Delta one which I
didn't talk about at all I think that's
going to depend very importantly on how
large and is and larger and probably
larger Delta and it kind of makes sense
right because if you think about it um
grent descent involves this gram Matrix
and if gram Matrix is identity one step
of grent descent will just give you the
solution uh and when n is very large the
gr Matrix does approach identity
uh whereas when it's small gram Matrix
could be U condition and you know how U
condition gram Matrix is is related to
the condition number of R Theta so you
Mak sense that for a smaller and you can
you have to take smaller Lar
all right so let's thank Shang
again